bu teknoloji nereye gidiyor Tabii ki
teknoloji deyince içerisine bir çok
şeydir Ama biz özellikle yazılımsal Ve
donanımsal biraz daha teknoloji
teknoloji Hani üretim vesaire den ölçer
dijital teknolojiden konuşacağız bugün
teknolojinin nereye gideceğini
anlayabilmemiz için Teknoloji ne
olduğunu nasıl gelişti ve şu anda nasıl
çalışıyor biraz bunu anlamamız lazım O
yüzden ben size En başından en sonuna ve
işte Önümüzdeki on yirmi yıla kadar bir
hikaye paylaşacağım nasıl başladık nasıl
ilerledik ve ne olacak bundan sonra o
yüzden başlayalım en başından önümüzde
şu anda bilgisayarlarımız var bilgisayar
derken Herşey kastediyoruz Tabii ki
telefonlar iPad'ler Efendim Kul
o laptop lak Bunlar nasıl çalışıyor Bir
kere bunu anlamamız lazım ki nereye
gideceğini iyice çözelim nasıl başladı
bütün bu süreç şimdi bütün konuşma
boyunca Yüz 200-300 Yıllık bir zaman
çizgisinde ilerleyeceğiz Aslında ben
size şu anda Yüzyıl geri alıyorum ve Bu
yüzyılda geriye aldığımda
bilgisayarların daha iyi temellerini
yavaş yavaş tabi bilgisayar derken o
zaman herhangi bir hesaplamanın
yapıldığı bir cihazdan bahsediyoruz
Aslında nasıl ortaya çıktığını V şu
andaki bilgisayarlı nasıl çalıştığını
anlamamız gerekiyor şu andaki
bilgisayarlarımız nasıl çalışıyor
bilgisayar dediğimiz şey aslında dört
tane ama temel iş yapar bir sizden girdi
alır input iki bunu hafızada saklar 3
bunu işler 4 size bir çıktı verir nedir
aldığı girdi
bu klavye miz masumuz şu anda
telefonumuzda lokasyonu muz koşuya
gidiyoruz o koşuyu takip ediyor vesaire
annenin kalp atışlarınızı takip ediyor
sesimizi takip ediyor Bütün bunların
hepsi birer biridir Siz klavyenizde a
tuşuna bastığınızda O bir bilgi olarak
bilgisayara verilir bu hafızada saklanır
buraya kadar çok büyük böyle teknolojik
bir şey yok ama aslında çığır açan şey
bunun işlenmesi burada bir işlem yapılır
ve size bir çıktı verilir çıktı da işte
ekranda gördüğünüz a harfi Ama bunun
işlenmesi süresince çok büyük işlemler
ve bundan Yüzyıl önce hiçbir şekilde
düşünemeyeceğimiz bazı operasyonlar
yapılıyor elektrikle çalışıyor
bilgisayarlar ve elektrikle derken Elif
şişe bağladım elektrikten öder bütün
işlemler elektrikle yapılıyor bizim bil
de kırmızın içerisinde bulunan
işlemcideki bir çok küçük kabloları
düşünün bunların içerisinde elektrik var
mı yok mu bu Takip ediliyor elektrik var
mı yok mu takip edilmesi ne demek bir
kablo da en fazla neyi takip
edebilirsiniz elektrik var ya da yok
yani bir ya da sıfır şimdi bütün
bilgisayarlar bir ve sıfırları anlar ve
bunlarla çalışır diyorduk bütün
bilgisayarlar bir ve sıfırları Anlat
Başka da aslında hiçbir şey anlamaz
bizim yazdığımız kodlar izlediğimiz
YouTube'daki videolar şu an Instagram'da
yaptığınız canlı yayın hem
telefonlarımız için bilgisayarlarımız
için birden ve sıfırdan ibaret Peki bunu
oluyor Çünkü aslında kapasitesi sadece o
elektrik telinin içerisinde bulunan
elektrik var mı yok mu Onu görebilmesi
Eğer bir tane kablosuz varsa 1 veya 0
değerini
bu biliyorsunuz eğer birden fazla
tablomuz varsa bir tane 10 bir tane daha
10 ve kibirleri sıfırları birileri
sıfırları sakladığınız Bütün bunlar
Nasıl oluyor da ben YouTube'da açıp kedi
köpek videosu izleyebiliyorum Yani nasıl
bu kadar ileri seviye bir teknolojiye
evriliyor birden sıfırlar burada Aslında
kullanılan sistem banyoya dediğimiz bir
ve sıfırdan oluşan rakamsal sistem Biz
günümüzde günlük hayatta resmin verimli
onluk sistemi kullanıyoruz değil mi 10
20 30 40 50 bin 3000000 deyince hangi
sayıdan bahsettiğimiz anlayabiliyorsun
fakat bilgisayar bunu anlamıyor bir
0101101 desem bunu sen anlamıyorsun ama
bilgisayar alıyor Şimdi 101011 sıfırı
herhangi bir onluk sayıya çevirmek
Aslında oldukça kolay biz nasıl onluk
sayı sistemi kullanıyor
O bilgisayarda ikilik sayı sistemi
kullanıyor İnternette Google herhangi
bir şekilde bi' rides Muğla çeviri
yazarsanız mesela çok kolay size çevirme
araçları gösterecektir Yani bütün
rakamlar Bütün sayılar birler ve sıfırla
Aslında ifade edilebilir şimdi bütün
rakamlar Bütün sayılar binlerle
sıfırlayıp ifade edilebiliyorsa Bu bize
çok büyük bir yol açıyor Aslında ne yol
açıyor Madem bütün rakamları binlerle
sıfırla Biz ifade edebiliyoruz O zaman
ben görselleri demirlerle sıfırla ifade
edebilirim videoları edebilirim sesleri
de edebilirim aklıma gelebilecek
Bilgisayar ekranında gördüm Her şeyi bir
lerle sıfırla ifade edebilirim çok kolay
hemen harflere birer tane sembolü rakam
Ata örneğim a10101 olsun 10 11
sağ olsun gibi düşünebilir Sen Sena'yı
da beyit Ece'yi de değil de sadece
elektrik devreleri ile oynayarak ifade
Edebilir hale geliyoruz ve mesela
görseller senin şu anda Fotoğrafını
çektiğim de bütün renk pikselleri yani o
görseli oluşturan en küçük parçanın renk
kodları bir Erbay representational yani
birer bayileri tanımına sahip ve böylece
bilgisayar onu algılayabiliyor Peki
seslerinizi algılıyor ses dediğimiz
nedir ve havadaki titreşimler havadaki
titreşimlerle Aslında dalga boyutları
olarak ifade edilebiliyor ve dalga
boyutlarının koordinatları ile beraber
Ben yine rakamsal bir yere çekebiliyorum
bu işi video dediğinde zaten sesler ve
görsellerin birleşimi Oyüzden Ben şu
andaki bütün yaptığımız Bu konuşmalar bu
iletişimler internete Gidip gelmesi
11'ler ve sıfırla ifade edilebiliyor
buraya geldiysek Artık yavaş yavaş
Matriks yaşadığımıza ikna olmuş
olabiliriz ama burada da bitmiyor bu
birler ve sıfırlar bize çok farklı
kapılarda açıyor Biz Toplama işlemini
çıkarma işlemini bunları farklı farklı
hallere getirme işlemini mantık
katkılarıyla ve devrelerle yapabiliyoruz
Örneğin bir verdiğinizde yeri y0 veren
devreler bir bir verdiğimizde bir veren
10 verdiğimizde sıfır veren farklı
farklı devrelerle Biz bilgisayarlara
istediğimiz işlemleri yaptırabiliyor Uz
bakın sadece elektriğin depolanmasında
yola çıkarak Şu anda ben bilgisayarımda
bilmem kaç gigabayt lık veriyi internete
yükleyip sana Beş dakika içerisinde
yolla ya bildiğin bir sisteme gitmişiz
bu çok çok büyük devrimsel bir düşünce
Aslında o sebeple şu an
bu İçinde bulunduğumuz teknoloji de bile
çok büyük bir gelişme kat ettik Biz
Bunlar daha da bu şekilde devam edecek
Biz bilgisayarımızda al tuşuna
bastığımızda bunu işlemcinizi kendi
içerisinde değerlendiriyor hesaplıyor ve
diyor ki şu şu hesapları Yap we6 şunu
çıktı olarak göster Bütün bu hesapları
yapmasını Aslında hesapları dediğimiz
bir dille Biz de bilgisayara
söyleyebiliyoruz ev sen mi dediğimizi
low-level yani düşük seviyeli
programlama dili ve daha önce şu anda
kullandığımız yüksek seviyeli
programlama dilleri yani python canavar
codling Swift vesaire olmadan önce
tamamen program yazmak için kullanılan
bir programlama dili gibi düşün işte biz
bu tarz dilleri kullanarak
bilgisayarlara hükmedebileceği başarmış
Yüzyıl
ve bu aslında sizi Yüzyıl geriye
götürmüştüm bir 40-50 yıl 60 yıl yetmiş
yıllık birikiminin getirdiği yer bizi
ama ondan sonra işler çok daha bir anda
farklı yerlere gitmeye başladı nereye
gitmeye başladı ve nereye gidecek
kuantum bilgisayarları mesela şu anda
gitmeye başladı Biz şu anda her ne kadar
teknolojik olarak gerçekten çok büyük
bir birisinin sonucunu kullanıyor
olsakta hala çözmek istediğimiz
problemler için yeterli değil yani Biz
şu anda işte kanserin çözümünü bulmamız
bir ilacın On senede çıkması coronanın
hala iyi bir aşısının olmaması veya çok
büyük yapay zeka çok büyük dip loring
sorumlularının hızlıca çözülememesi
Bizim her zaman bazı limitasyon larla
karşılaşma
her türlü oluyor dünyanın en güzel
bilgisayarını en hızlı bilgisayarını da
oluşturursanız aslında o bir lerle ve
sıfırla çalışıyordu takip kuantum
bilgisayar ortaya çıkana kadar şimdi şu
zamana kadar anlattığım her şeyi çöpe
atacak bir teknolojinin eşiğindeyiz
Muhtemelen belli bir süre sonra on yıl
sonra tekrar bu konuşmayı yaptığımızda
çok daha farklı şeyler konuşacağız nedir
peki kuantum bilgisayar bunu
anlayabilmek için de kuantum
anlayabilmemiz gerekiyor o sebeple Ben
sizi şimdi Time bayan zaman çizgi filmi
çok daha farklı yerlere götürmek
zorundayım kuantum Aslında Kuantum
mekaniği fiziğin bir balı ve fizikte
dünyamızı evrenimizin nasıl çalıştığını
anlayabilmek için fizikçilerin
geliştirdiği bir dal veya fizikçilerin
keşfettiği birçok
bu birikimden oluşan bir dal diyebiliriz
ne zaman başladı bu çok önce başladı
Tabii ki hani arşivlediğin suyun
kaldırma kuvveti ne kadar geriye
gidebiliriz ama oraya kadar gitmeye
gerek yok belki nevtona kadar geriye
gidebilir mi 300 yıl geriye götüreyim
sizi Newton kendi başına oturup
yerçekiminden bütün Şu anda
kullandığımız fizik denklemlerini yazana
kadar Aslında dünyanın nasıl
çalıştığıyla ilgili çok büyük bir
fikrimiz yoktu bu adam kendi başına
dünyanın en iyi bilim adamı olana kadar
o zamana kadar görülmüş en iyi bilim
adamı olduğu için bütün bunları buldu ve
yüzyıllarca biz bu formüllerin üstünde
işlemler yaptık Ama bu Tabii ki yeterli
değildir ne zaman geldik 2900 onlara
burada Size yine bir yüzyılda geri
götürmüş olacağım ama en azından Lipton
iç Yüzyıl ileri gittik o zaman aynı
ve onay işlemleri ki ben evrenin nasıl
çalıştığını çözeceğim ve bize iki tane
Gerçekten insan aklının Yüzyıl önce
nasıl bulunduğunu kavramaya cağı iyi
teori verdi Bir özel Görelilik teorisi
iki genel Görelilik teorisi bu özel
Görelilik teorisinin bulurken tamamen
Genelde öyle matematik işlemleriyle ve
yaptığı Aslında formüllerle çıkarım
larıyla bulduğu sonuçlarla bize bulup
ifade etti o zaman ne büyük kadron
çarpıştırıcısı vardı ne de farklı bir
şey vardı ama o bizim evrenin nasıl
çalıştığını anlamamıza yardımcı oldu
gerçekten zamanın görevliliğini gördük
hızla birlikte zamanın değişebileceğini
gördük ve bunu matematiksel olarak adam
bize ispat etti bütün bunlari Einstein
teorileri okuduğunuzda sayısı kişi gibi
durursa bilim kurgu gibi dursa bile şu
an
bu günümüzde Gerçekten bu prensipleri
kullanmasak dünyamızın çökeceği birçok
teknoloji var uydularımız şu anda özel
Görelilik teorisinin bize sunduğu bazı
çıkarımları kullanarak işlemler yapıyor
Eğer ki zamanı edus etmese Oradaki kıza
göre zamanı ayarlaması Dünyada hiçbir
GPS sisteminin düzgün çalışmayacağı
şeker şimdi genel Görelilik teorisi çok
daha büyük zaten zaman ve uzayın nasıl
büküldüğü ve yerçekiminin bunun adı etki
ettiğini söylüyor ve bütün bunlar Burayı
çok Uzatmaya gerek yok genel evrenin
nasıl çalıştığını bize gösterdi ama
ondan sonra Einstein maalesef zamanın
yetmediği Kuantum mekaniği ortaya çıktı
orada nasıl Biz Einstein da dünyayı
evrenin çok büyük şeyleri Makro düzeyde
anladıysak kuantumda mikro düzeyde en
küçük
Bu nasıl çalıştığını keşfetmeye başladık
Ve atomaltı parçacıkların nasıl davranış
gösterdiğini görmeye çalıştık atom
altına indikçe kuantum çok küçük
parçalarla çok izole parçalarını ya da
çok soğuk parçalarla ilgilenen bilim
dalı Aslında kuantum-a girdiğimizde
günlük fizik prensipleri ile
açıklanamayacak bir çok şeyin olduğunu
gördük bunlardan üç tanesini kuantum
bilgisayarlar kullanarak dünyamızı
değiştirecek 3 prensibe Gelecek olursak
hemen birincisi süper poz için dediğimiz
süperpozisyon işte şimdi konuşmanın
başına dönüyorum bir ve sıfırla çalışan
bilgisayarımız artık bir ve sıfırla
çalışmak zorunda olmayacak Bu bir ve
sıfırlar bit dediğimiz en küçük veri
depolayabilen ölçüden artık Tüh bit
dediğimiz korktum bir dediğimiz bir ve 0
şu anda süperpozisyon olarak
barındırabilecek bir sisteme geçiyor
montumda baktıklarında atomaltı
parçacıkların Aslında gözlemlediği
sürece her iki siteyi de yani ya bir de
yansıtır da ya orada ya burada
bulunabileceği idi keşfediyor bilim
adamları ve Buna anlam erdiremiyorum var
çünkü şu zamana kadar gördüğünüz hiçbir
şeyle uyumlu bir davranış değil bu Ama
biz şu anda da kuantum bilgisayarları
çok soğuk bir hale getirerek mutlak zi
sıfıra neredeyse yakın bir hale
getirerek kuantu superpose işığı
oluştura biliyoruz Ve artık bir ve sıfır
değil 10 aynı anda kullanabiliyoruz ama
Daha da fazlası var İki tane daha
prensibimiz var Birincisi entel yıllık
Yani dolanıklık teorisidir yine atom
altı parçacıklarda incelediğimizde 2
o parçacığın Eğer ki dolanıklık
prensibine sahipse birbirine el bir
şekilde bağlı olduğu ve birbiriyle
birlikte hareket ettiğini Aslında
söylüyorlar bunun en iyi anlatım yolu
şudur biri parayı elimde tuttuğum da
madeni parayı yazın olduğunu turam
olduğunu sis söyleyebilirsiniz ya bir ya
sıfır diyebilirsiniz Fakat ben bunu
havaya atarsan dönerken aynı anda bir ve
sıfır süper pozisyonunda olduğunu
düşündüm iki tane madeni parayı havaya
atarsa ikisinide yere düştüğünde ya
2'sinde Tura gelmesi lazım ya 2'sinde
Yazı gelmesi lazım işte bu da Entegre
olur yani dolanıklık teorisi şimdi eğer
ki ben birden fazla kübit birbirine
entangle edebilirsem bir anda hesaplama
Kapasiten exponential olarak artıyor
yani İki üzeri en olarak artıyor Eğer 50
tane köy bitim varsa 250/50
daha fazla işlem yapabiliyorum ve üçüncü
prensipler infinus yani birbiriyle
çakışma bu ya birbirini aç olayları iki
tane Deryada birbirini güçlendirir öyle
düşünüp birbirine güçlendirerek çok çok
şu anda Aklımızın almayacağı kadar hızlı
işlemler yapabilen bilgisayarlar
üretebiliyoruz şu anda bizim en güçlü
bilgisayarımızın yüz binlerce yıl da
hesaplamalarını kontum bilgisayarlarla
birkaç saatte yapabilir hale 2020
itibariyle geldik işte teknoloji buraya
video tamamen Aklımızın hayalimizin
alamayacağı bir yere gidiyor şu anda
dünyada kuantum bilgisayarların nasıl
çalıştığını anlayan ve baştan sonra
bütün prensiplerine hakim olan 800
kişinin olduğu düşünülüyor 800 kişi çok
çok çok küçük bir
Ya aslında 800 kişi demek kimse bilmiyor
daha bu işi demek o sebeple bir on yıl
sonra korktum bilgisayarlar hayatınızda
olacak ki şu anda hayatımızda şu an Ay
bir Google'ın sitelerine girerseniz
kuantum bilgisayarları kulaktan yani
İnternetten ulaşıp onlar üstünde
devreler oluşturup kod yazmaya
başlayabilirsiniz bunu hazırmısınız bir
bu önemli iki bundan sonra değişim çok
daha hızlı olacak şu an bilmediğim Belki
bir sürü şey gelecek karşımıza şu an
bende bilmiyorum beş yıl sonra kontrol
programı ne hale geleceğini buna
kendimizi adapte edebilir miyiz en büyük
konuşacağımız şeyler bunlar olacak bu
sebeple yazılımı öğrenmek teknolojiyi
takip etmek ve her zamankinden daha zor
ama her zamankinden daha da kolay çünkü
bilgiye aç
Bu sıra size işimiz var evinizin
konforunda Biz yazılım öğrenebiliriz
sadece ve sadece buna kendimizi adamımız
ve bundan sonraki değişimleri kendimizi
hazırlamamız gerekiyor şu zamana kadar
yüz binlerce yıl sürecek hesaplamalar
Eğer birkaç saatte yapılabiliyorsa bizim
onlarca yıl bir ilaç çıksın diye
beklememize gerek kalmayacak yüzyıllarca
sürecek de şifrelerinin kırılması çok
daha hızlı bir şekilde olacak farklı
güvenlik sistemlerine ihtiyaç duyacağız
şu zamana kadar çözülemeyen yapay zeka
ve makine öğrenmesi Deep learning
problemleri çok kısa bir sürede
çözülmeye başlayacak ve bütün bulmak Sen
Fikri gibi dursa da çok kısa bir sürede
Olacak ve şu anda oluyor